[Music]  growing up Mormon growing up in yogas  Church being Mormon I felt like being  gay just wasn't an option  we were about as evil as a thing and yet  Utah's problem is that our suicide rate  has been climbing and that's appalling  you can't sit and see a kid talk about  how there are only two options is easy  to live the church or to commit suicide  the church has made it fairly clear  where they stand if you can't get on  this ship those of us that are in the  trenches are gonna make it happen and  that's what Mama dragons do in the book  how to be a perfect Mormon mother  there's no chapter how to parent your  gay kid  mama dragons is helping to write that  chapter  [Music]